the man who has been promoting boxing
and being part of the boxing world for
decades now and getting set for a big
time saturday in december december 11th
when he and top rank are promoting a
highly anticipated lightweight battle
between former champions facility
lomachenko and richard comey
at madison square garden it'll be live
on espn right after the heisman trophy
ceremony good to have here brooklyn's
finest bob arum here on the rich eisen
show in person how are you bob good nice
to see you again good to see you it's
been a few years yeah it's been a while
good to see you it's good to see you so
uh let me just jump into this with a
little memory lane if you don't mind
when was the first time you met muhammad
ali bob let's just jump right into that
would be in 1965. okay and uh
uh
i had met
the great football player jim brown
and brown
said
uh that
i should be ali's promoter and lawyer
i had never seen a boxing match but i
had handled the big case
as a prosecutor in the u.s attorney's
office when we seized all the money in
the patterson list and fight the sdn why
right that's what you were with this
other day southern famous southern
district right
and uh
so
i met uh
uh
uh ali and uh his advisor then herbert
muhammad and jim in a meeting
and they shipped me out to chicago to
get the blessing of the honorable elijah
muhammad
and i got that blessing and
scheduled a fight uh march of 66
with ernie tyrell in chicago
and ali
while he was training in miami
uh
was reclassified
from one why because at that point he
was functionally illiterate so he
couldn't pass the test
and they made him one a
and then bob haller in the cbs
uh in miami interviewed him and that's
when ali said i ain't going to vietnam i
ain't going to fight the vietcong they
never used the n-word to me i'm just not
going
and mayor daley
uh in chicago where the fight tyrell
fight was going to be held kicked us out
we got
couldn't find a venue any place in the
united states we ended up in toronto and
that was my first fight last year
in march of 1966
ali and chavalo for the heavyweight
championship welcome to boxing that was
your that was your welcome to boxing no
but it was great because if
when people come up to me
and say oh this was a tough promotion
that you've done you know like
a year ago or whatever i said a piece of
cake compared to my first one
it all kind of broke you in and made
everything that much easier from there
on out yeah it did it certainly did and
i wouldn't have stayed
except i was so angry what they were
doing to ali
who by that time i had really gotten
close to
that i stayed around to fight everything
and took them to
england and then germany
and then judge roy hopfines
who owned the astrodome had us come back
to the united states
and fight a couple of fights there and
he fought then one zora foley in the
garden and that was that he was off for
three and a half years
they took his passport
nobody would license them i mean
horrible the way they treated him
what was he like not when he wasn't in
front of a camera the greatest i mean
terrific better
when he wasn't in front of the camera he
was a warm generous human being
highly intelligent
although again when i met him he was
functionally illiterate he learned that
a reading right but he was very very
astute and intelligent
but really nice
really nice i'm not just saying this
because he's no longer here but he was a
really nice person
well i mean because again
we could spend hours talking about the
people who you have promoted uh fights
that you've promoted from george foreman
to obviously manny pacquiao and
marvelous marvin hagler and and and the
names that just jump off the list sugar
ray and uh tyson and now tyson fury
you've done a couple of fights you said
you just got off the phone with him a
couple of hours
promoting tyson fury
uh for the last four fights
and uh he's a real character i mean he
is
larger than life and not just because
he's so tall he's just a
a great entertainer and a great
personality and also a great guy
i mean really and i what i've
i've really you know
with a guy like tyson fury who comes
from a very
distinct background
uh he's uh from the
gypsy nation uh
lived in ireland and then
uh northern england uh
the whole gypsy culture is real i don't
want to go into it necessarily here but
it's really really interesting
and
so the when i i've made it a point to
spend time with him uh talking about
different things not just boxing and
i've learned a lot
which i didn't wasn't aware of of the
gypsy culture
very interesting he was here a couple
years ago bob and we we were talking to
him and everyone who who who came with
him and i didn't understand a word they
were saying to be very honest with you
it was he he he he speaks so fast and
then he he he sat down here
and he was so
remarkable in sharing his struggles with
mental health and how he is so open
about it
and how it's important to hear him that
somebody who is such a hulking
individual of of a man
who can break you in two
who
gets off the mat right
after he's been knocked down talk about
how he's
struggling with what's in between his
temples is so important i think for
people to hear that story right and what
he's told me
is even when there's no fight on the
horizon and because of the pandemic he
went over a year
between the second fight with wilder and
the third
he was able to keep his sanity by going
into the gym
twice a day to train train train
because he felt he that
training like that
even when there was no fight on the
horizon uh kept him mentally stable
what's next for him
well now we're
very interesting
uh
anthony joshua lost
alexander usic
who's now has some of the belts
and we're trying to get there's a
rematch clause joshua to step aside
so that
uh
tyson can fight usyk for all
four belts that would be a unified
title
and
they're talking about doing it
in saudi arabia
which
wants to stage that fight
in march hopefully it'll all come
together
if it doesn't
if uh joshua insists on the rematch with
usyk
then fury will fight
dylan white who's the number one
contender and we do that fight
uh
sort of a homecoming uh for tyson uh in
an arena
in manchester uh where he comes from bob
arum here on the rich eisen show what's
the
biggest fight that you weren't able to
make
in your career that you're like you know
what
there was so much mishigos to use the
word uh that just you couldn't get it
done or you you wanted to get it done
and couldn't get done which one is that
you know bob
ultimately i got it done i mean the
pacquiao fight
with uh
uh with mayweather that went on for five
years with a lot of nonsense
until we finally got it done and it was
the biggest
uh
from a standpoint of money the biggest
fight ever
uh when they finally fought the fight
that i haven't been able to get done
uh is terence crawford and errol spence
uh
because
uh
frankly the two fighters want so much
money
and while it is a great fight in the
ring and by hardcore boxing fans love it
it doesn't pencil out
uh
as far as pay-per-view
which is not as robust
as it was
uh five or ten years ago
when you say nonsense what do you mean
by nonsense when you said the nonsense
with the pacquiao and
it was drug testing there was always an
excuse
why the fight couldn't happen
so meanwhile floyd went his way
manny went his way they each made a lot
of money during that period
but we couldn't get them together it
took five years to get them together
but when we got them together we did
over four million
uh pay-per-view homes uh and hundreds
hundreds of millions of dollars
so
maybe it was all worth it in the end bob
aaron here on the rich eisen show um
when i say the name don king you think
of what do you think king was a rival
for a long time right
and
uh he came from a different place from
the place that i came from
i mean he had served time in prison and
he was a real street guy
but he had a a way of his expressing
himself
that
caused people to notice
uh he was a very good promoter
uh but he was a vicious competitor
but when the fight had to be made
with his fighter and my fighter
who found a way to do it and he was a
good partner
whether it was leonard and duran first
fight in montreal
or oscar de la hoya and trinidad i did a
number of fights with king
and they were all
you know very successful ventures did
you get along with them or not really
only when we were counting up the money
did you have to look to see if you were
getting your share no but i was
we collected that was positive
we collected
you were doing the collection and
disbursement is what you're saying what
you were doing the collective companies
you're right and then we were dividing
it
so i didn't have that angst other which
i would have otherwise might have had
well i guess that's why you're so good
at it and why you've done it for so long
bob arum and so um
wow so the do you do you have a nomas
story that we don't know about anything
like that you mentioned i mean
durant story and you know roberto duran
or anything i just i i know what
happened
i mean
uh i mean it's clear what happened
because i subsequently became duran's
promoter
when he fought iran barclay in one of
the great middleweight fights
uh and then a third fight with sugar ray
lennon
what happened and duran expressed it to
me and it was true
is
once when duran beat
uh leonard in the first fight in
montreal yes
he went back to panama and he was like
the king
and he acted like the king
i visited him subsequently he had a
house that had expanded and there was a
pool in the back
and he would have 40 people over
uh eating steaks and drinking champagne
and having a great time and the last
thing in his mind then was fighting
and then
mike traynor who was the manager of ray
leonard
told
king in effect
you guys can keep all the money we just
want the rematch because ray felt he
could beat him
and
so carlos aletta and king
cut off a lot of money
and
they they forced in effect duran into
that second fight before he was ready
duran
trained for the second fight basically
just to lose weight
and
after the weigh-in
he gorged himself
on two stakes and i mean crazy
and so he was in no real
condition to fight you know not fighting
conditions
and ray played with him
danced around him
and
duran couldn't even hit him and was
being humiliated and he quit
that was it he was angry at everybody
and he quit
so you've also um promoted four mike
tyson fights what was that like
promoting a mike tyson fight bob arum
for you well you know tyson at that
point was crazy
his manager and his
his uh
uh
managers were
were in fear of him
they were afraid
to let him loose between fights they put
a lot of pressure we were doing there's
weekly shows
uh for espn from 1980 to 1985. so this
was in that during that period and they
wanted him to fight once a week because
otherwise he would get into terrible
terrible trouble
and he had established a reputation of
being this real killer
and
so
it was hilarious you'd put him in with a
fairly good professional
and you could see
the opponent's
knees shaking right and so tyson would
walk across the ring throw one punch
knock him out and that was that
but you know it it became
it wasn't good television it you know it
seems great you know knockout and so
forth but when it goes on repeatedly
four quick knockouts we weren't getting
uh
the air time that was required and we
stopped promoting
so let's talk about what you got going
on here uh coming up on december 11th i
got the list right here this is going to
be your
864th boxing show promoted on espn yeah
thank you
that's a that's a hefty number that's a
whopping fine number as dr seuss once
said this is your
48th boxing show promoted in new york
city madison
in the mecca
i mean i imagine you went you probably
grew up watching some events there in
madison absolutely i mean my father
took me
uh
to watch college basketball sure he was
a graduate of nyu
and nyu had some great teams all the the
nyu saint john's liu
city college and the nit was king right
yeah right
uh so
i mean the garden was legendary he was
in a different area at the time right
but i was there when they first opened
the garden
uh at the new garden
and i was always in awe
of the any new york guy
was in or of madison square garden
and
so i'm really thrilled uh again to go
back uh it's
my
uh
90th birthday
three days before right three days
before and so the family will be there
and it's a great fight uh lomachenko is
a tremendous tremendous fighter uh and
he's fighting comey he's a big knockout
guy
but interesting we have some great kids
on the you know the future on the card i
have
muhammad ali's grandson that amazing you
know he's he's a he's a lovely young man
i knew his mother when she was a little
girl sure yeah rashida uh and uh
some terrific pro
prospects like uh
zanda
zayas
uh
and
keyshawn davis who we sign
who probably was one of the best silver
medalists uh olympians yeah won a silver
medal uh so i'm really pumped uh to be
back
uh in my home city not amazing you know
because
i've lived in las vegas since 1986
but you can tell my my accent and i'm
still in new york of course i know that
i'm i'm you know i'm i'm born in
brooklyn raising staten island it comes
out if you cut me off in traffic bob
i'll be honest with you so uh all right
two two two last things for you
do you have a sinatra story have you
ever come across frank
at boxing
yeah yeah yeah what do you got for me
well
a number of years ago i had my late
friend saw kurzner
who built and owned sun city
in papua suanna which was the homeland
in south africa
had sinatra there singing
and
uh
saul was a big boxing fan
and i came up with an idea
that
we would do two championship fights
uh and then sinatra would do a concert
and mickey rudin great
late mickey rudin the lawyer for sinatra
was in the hotel and sinatra was in the
hotel in the saint regis in new york
so rooney said what a ridiculous idea
frank could never go for it
so i said well let me go up and talk to
him with with them
and i started talking to them i do we do
uh
duran against davey moore
and
sinatra
i could see he wasn't interested
and then he said and what was the other
fight and i said ray mancini against
kenny pott he said mancini i said yes he
said i'm in
i mean got him in boom boom boom he was
a crazy boombo mancini fan
so we
we set up we signed a contract we set up
a press conference and sinatra was at
the press conference and
uh it was going to be on closed circuit
in the united states and
uh
and
everything was going swimmingly well i
don't know i in those days
we were not sophisticated so i wrote the
commercials
so i remember going with louvo pacelli
my director to the kennedy center where
sinatra was to have sinatra do the
commercial and he looked at it
and he said terrible and he then did his
own commercial
for which was great okay right
and
a week before the fight
uh in training in south africa
uh ray collar bone was broken
and once that happened sinatra pulled
out
it went down we called it we were
calling it chairman and the champs it
never happened but sinatra i found was a
really great guy terrific guy to work
with fun guy i really i really admired
him rod and hein april shot down in may
i guess that's right
oh my gosh
you almost had it what what a night that
would have been yeah how about that
sinatra's a ray boom boom mancini fan
you probably never thought that was
coming today
that's amazing
um so
last one for you uh we in this realm of
sports talk um always put
people on the spot by saying give us
your mount rushmore
means you got to give me four
of fighters
do you have one for me yeah bob barum
your mountain rushmore mount rushmore of
fighters
muhammad ali okay right
marvelous marvin hagler
all right
uh manny pacquiao
and tyson fury
those are your four yeah etch it in
stone
yeah haggler's a good one huh yeah
hagler was the best what a great guy
well they don't call him marvelous for
nothing right exactly and you know he
passed well before his time
and ollie and fury get in the ring what
do you what happens there do you think
fury wins no no heavy weight
no heavy weight
before
or since
could beat fury the fury is
so incredible guys who were six nine
were bums
when ali was fighting right because they
couldn't move and
and there were always flaws
but here's a guy fury takes an
incredible punch
uh moves like a a welterweight
and has a pretty good punch himself
knows how to box
we haven't seen that combination ever
ever
you know i feel sorry for wilder
who's a terrific fighter
because he came in an era that gave us
uh tyson fury and remember it's not a
fluke because
tyson fury
beat valh
walamir klitschko
when klitschko was riding high and
nobody
gave fury a chance
fury is the goods because he can box he
can punch
and he keeps getting better
happy birthday in advance bob aaron
thank you very much turn 90. all right
on december 8th
it's only a number bob aaron certainly
since you know i uh i mean clearly
you're at the top of your game that's
the you put the top in top ranked boxing
that's for sure this has been a pleasure
i know i i i met you a couple years ago
you're like i'll do it i'm no problem
just invite and i'm glad we finally got
it done yeah thank you good much much
much pleasure and then again uh uh happy
uh happy birthday and then everybody
check out uh uh comey versus lomachenko
and so much more on espn stay tuned
right after the heisman trophy ceremony
on december the 11th good to see you sir
thank you bob aaron right here on the
rich eisen show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here